este 25 de noviembre miles de mujeres
han salido a las calles de colombia para
conmemorar el día internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer que este año tiene una coyuntura
especial debido a la pandemia que ha
agravado los derechos de las mujeres
dejando cifras alarmantes en colombia al
menos 243 mujeres fueron víctimas de
feminicidios durante los meses de
cuarentena pero además las cuarentenas y
el aislamiento lleva a que muchas
mujeres estuvieran encerradas con sus
agresores lo que provoca un aumento en
las llamadas a las líneas de atención
del ciento 63 por ciento sólo en el
primer mes de confinamiento por ello
muchas mujeres de colombia de distintas
agrupaciones feministas han organizado
una multitudinaria marcha en la que se
han llevado a cabo diferentes actos
reivindicativos actuaciones musicales
intervenciones artísticas también
pañuelazos frente a la corte para
reivindicar el derecho al aborto de las
mujeres en colombia y una marcha a la
que han participado mujeres de todas las
edades en las que están reivindicando el
derecho de las mujeres al de a una vida
sin violencia
eso en cuanto a colombia pero si hay un
país que padece la violencia de género y
los feminicidios es méxico
allí también miles de mujeres salieron a
las calles para rechazar la violencia
machista
-mario carbón el corresponsal de france
24 en ciudad de méxico estuvo en una de
estas marchas en la capital mexicana y
nos cuenta en detalle en el siguiente
reporte
en este 25 de noviembre las mujeres en
la ciudad de mexico salen a las calles
consideran que el virus de la violencia
contra las mujeres es igual o más
peligroso que el virus del cob y aquí
está araceli osorio quien se ha
convertido en un emblema de la lucha
contra el feminicidio tras el
feminicidio de su hija cómo estás
araceli que te atraparán
pues no
lo que nos hace salir a las calles sigue
siendo
y presencia a las que ya no están a las
que nos han arrebatado de las maneras
más crueles a las que no nos se murieron
nos asesinaron darles voz a las mujeres
que de momento no se encuentran en sus
hogares porque a alguien se la llevó no
desaparecieron o alguien se las llevó y
tenemos que encontrarnos para que nos
digan qué fue lo que pasó quién se las
llevó y por qué todo esto salimos a las
calles porque en méxico a pesar de que
ha llegado otro gobierno nos siguen
asesinando a las mujeres nos siguen
desapareciendo siguen ejerciendo
violencia sobre nuestros cuerpos y ahora
más
y así es en un país donde entre enero y
octubre hay más de 800 feminicidios 8 de
cada 10 mujeres tienen miedo de salir a
la calle por temor a ser agredidas y
seis de cada diez mujeres han sufrido
algún tipo de violencia por eso
protestan las mujeres en méjico en este
vídeo
[Música]